in recruitment and growing recruitment
companies it's very common that elliot
might be the commercial person in that
setup but elliott also is expected to do
the training to do the the thing so then
all of a sudden like you said they're
not running really fast in a small box
they're trying to run fast in a really
big box right so i think that that's
unique thing which which i really like
very typical for a recruitment company
although it does seem like shifting now
where people really have if you want to
be like a recruiter in a delivery role
they have sort of career progression
plans for that and just that it's not
just 360 like how have you set up the
actual recruiters themselves are they
going straight into candidates obviously
i know you've got that commercial person
they're winning business like are they
just on the candidate side initially
what does that look like so there are
360 consultant everyone we hire is not
delivery candidate focus everyone picks
up the phone emails clients candidates
from day one we're not going to hire any
180 consultants the the commercial
person is there really to pick up on
work that has already been done by the
consultant and make sure it's at the
right level and they're helping out to
maintain the right client relationships
and and and really kind of consultants
get the bites commercial will convert
those fights into jobs vp will then help
consultant to place that job close
candidates and
people ops person will train them to do
all of those parts really well and use
the system properly so everyone who
comes in is not sharing deals is not
like doing just candidate work or
head-hunting they are in an area in
specific niche but they do everything
like that they're a complete 360
recruiter they just have different
people to go to for help in different
ways to make the whole thing go faster
the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker
[Music]